As we kick off Beauty Week, I can't have thought
or dreamt to have done it with anyone like you.
When do you feel most beautiful?
I have to say, I feel pretty beautiful talking
to you because it's amazing to talk
to another woman you admire and bounce back and forth
with her and look at her beautiful, bouncy hair.
You have really bouncy hair.
(audience softly laughing)
Thank you, it's all Mr. Daniel.
Thank you, Mr. Daniel, for blessing us.
(audience loudly laughing)
And I feel beautiful when I'm directing.
I love to feel like I'm in charge
but I love to do it in a way that's gentle
and in a way that honors other people's creative process,
and just to gently move a process along
and to express my vision and bounce off someone else's.
And I love to just wear those headphones
and wear those boots and tromp around
and like midday, on a long shoot day
and like, you've just had your third coffee of the day
and you're about to like charge up a hill,
like that's a really good feeling.
I relate to you because I feel like I grew up,
I was like an adult, I wasn't a kid.
I never felt like a kid.
I was always interested in
a bigger-picture thinking, living in conversations
even when I was young.
You know, I didn't live my childhood
in the public eye the way that you did,
but I've lived a very pivotal period from 23 to 34
under a specific kind of scrutiny.
And I think watching the way
that you have navigated that so gracefully
and that you have actually carved your own path
and actually decided to define your own chapters,
that's something that I've taken a lot of heart in
at moments where I felt like other people were
maybe making those definitions for me.
So your journey has not gone unnoticed
by this little wanderer.
Thank you so much for that.
One of the things I love about you
and that I've tried to do a lot
in my life is be open to listening to all of it
and putting it through your own funnel,
however you interpret it.
A lot of people, it's hard to hear everything.
It's not easy, takes a spine and a sense of humor.
Yeah, and there've been times
that people have told me things,
by people, I mean the public,
that have been really important for me to hear,
things that were really important for me to hear.
And there've been times that I've received criticism
that I knew was the voice of a system, a patriarchal system.
A system that didn't like to hear noisy women.
A system that didn't like to hear women
who wanted to talk about their bodies,
women who want to talk about sex,
women who want to talk about their libidos,
women who want to talk about their anger.
And I really had to try to separate what was useful
and valid criticism that I needed to internalize
in order to grow and become the person
that I knew I wanted to be.
And yes, it does take being able to really hear
and also really be able to laugh at yourself.
Lena's journey to self-love has included
some serious health struggles.
She lives with Ehlers-Danlos syndrome,
which causes joint pain and other issues,
as well as endometriosis
for which she underwent a hysterectomy at age 31.
Now you've talked a lot about health.
You mentioned the body and just everything
that a lot of people are not comfortable talking about,
they're not comfortable listening to.
This is men and women, this is a genderless issue.
Will you talk to me about your health,
where you've been, where it's at now?
Because I have been wrapped in your journey as a woman.
Well, that means so much.
And from the beginning of my health struggle,
something that I was really committed to was the idea
that I was not going to keep it a secret
because we're in a culture that sees illness as weakness.
We're in a culture that sees sick women
as hysterical women, and we're in a business, you and I,
that doesn't look kindly on illness
because we, people are working at such a pace
with so much money involved
that for someone to be in any way
unable to show up or potentially a liability.
And so I wanted to bring it out into the open.
I knew for a long time that I was sick with endometriosis.
It caused enormous amount of pain, health challenges,
but I also knew something deeper was going on with my body.
And so I undertook an exploration
and came to understand that I also have
an underlying health condition called Ehlers-Danlos syndrome
which is a connective tissue disease that causes
like diffuse musculoskeletal pain and a number
of other sort of random but interlinked symptoms.
I also have a form of autoimmune arthritis
that is associated with it,
and so I also deal with autoimmune issues at the same time.
And so all of that came together in my 20s
to make a pretty miserable,
when I wasn't treating it,
to make a pretty miserable health picture
and sort of culminated in my having a hysterectomy
and one of my ovaries removed at 31.
Which was terrifying,
not just because it was a massive surgery,
but because I really want to be a mom
and had always thought that I was going
to do it in the traditional way.
And I don't think I realized how much I was going
to grieve that and how intense that process was going to be.
And I have to say though, the process of being able
to be open about that and write about that
and understand how many other women, how many other people,
how many other couples have grieved that alone
and together was one of the most healing things
I've ever experienced.
(bright music)